wir schauen mal ob das rote Telefon das
ist nämlich zurück in der Weltpolitik
das rote Telefon das in Zeiten des
Kalten Kriegs der heimliche heiße Draht
war zwischen Moskau und Washington da
steht jetzt hier guck mal da an der am
Rand vom Tisch im Kanzleramt ja das ist
ein Foto von Telefonat das Kanzlers mit
Putin und seitdem spricht Deutschland
über dieses Jahr etwas altbacken aus der
rote Telefon wir nennen das schon zu
Front ja das ist nach Bildinformation
ein hochsicherheitstelefon Sina
Communicator h so heißt das Ding
offiziell Parlamentschef Ralf Schuler
bei uns im Studio alles top secret über
dieses Telefon wie laufen solche
Telefonate im Kanzleramt ab das wäre
wählt dann die Nummer von Putin das ist
in der Tat recht neu dieses Telefon und
hat eine sehr komplizierte Ende zu Ende
verschlossen das ist ganz neu das steht
noch nicht lange da und wird glaube ich
soweit ich weiß auch noch nicht benutzt
weil es immer darauf ankommt dass die
Gegenseite auch sowas hat das ist jetzt
nicht vorbereitet aber hochsicherheit
also die die Verschlüsselung dieses
Gerät spricht mit dem anderen Gerät
darüber wie verschlüsseln wir denn und
dann tauschen die sich gegenseitig die
Codes aus spannende Geschichte
grundsätzlich sind solche Telefonate
eine schwieriges Unterfangen das wird
ersten Termin vereinbart dann stellt das
Lagezentrum im Kanzleramt das ist im
ersten oder zweiten Stock wenn ich es
richtig in Erinnerung habe stellt dann
die Verbindung her das sind auch
hochsicherheitsleitungen angeblich
komplett abhörsicher wobei das letzte
Stück zwischen Lagezentrum und dem
Kanzler manchmal dann unsicher ist er
kann sich das auch auf seinen
verschlüsseltes Handy geben lassen dann
werden diese Leitung hergestellt und
dann erst wenn beide bereit sind wird
das freigeschaltet und dann spricht man
man spricht obwohl Putin deutsch spricht
auf jeder in seiner Muttersprache das
internationales Protokoll und lässt das
dann übersetzen damit das wegen dauert
es dann auch so lange bis man 90 Minuten
das Gespräch also das zieht sich ja
wahnsinnig länger da übersetzt wird also
das wird das wird von von den jeweiligen
St
hergestellt diese Leitung und dann
beginnt man zu sprechen das ist ein
relativ komplizierte und langwierige
Geschichte aber es kommt dann dort nicht
dazu dass Scholz dann an seinem
Schreibtisch sitzt und in seinem kleinen
Heftchen nachblättert Putin Putin
Moskau das machen die anderen aber es
ist eine spannende Geschichte jeder
veröffentlicht dann im Prinzip nur das
was er möchte also was er gesagt hat und
was er raus lassen möchte und die andere
Seite dann auch
hochmodernes rotes Telefon auf dem Tisch
des Kanzlers und Ralf Schüler mit allen
Informationen zu den auch Inhalt danke
dir und Abläufen dieser Telefonate danke
[Musik]